>>>EN MILLIENTE FIVE .
STATES SGREASES
OR THE PEARCH MORETHAN 8% A POS.
WITHLERPEINDOORS, G HEDICTED WOA
AMERICANS AZEDNAVIRUS, AND 19 SS
ARE TION.
IT INTAH WHERE A
MANDATE FOR FACE INWE EFFECT.REE
PEOPLE WHO HAD ACTUAECEIVEDTHE N
US. JHE
CEO TS
CHANGER.R. COULD BE A TOOL AGAPD
HO
D RIGHT  I PART O THE00 PEOPLE
IVHEY WERE P THIUD FORWOARS, AN
THIS- WEIL LOOKINGT THEILITY OFE
RESP>> A LOT PEOPLE ROV ON
TH ONYWAY ORAVASE.
WHAT SAY A
PROTECON THICC WHAT CAN WE RO
CODIUM,
DE VERSE MIL
>> BOTH EXCELLENTTI TNK WNSWER
ALSO SECONDARY AT
DAYS, SO WE NOSE
INRMWHICH THE STUDY I  WHENFDA.T
THIS LYEO T IT.
TWISUTION AND TECOND IS I GUT O
HUNDREDS OFFES
ALY, MAYBE T MILLIONS BY OF 100
WE ARE I G SITUA 5
MILLION DOSR
I BELIE IERY, VOD 1.ONN NEXT YE
OCTOBER I DU FOR
AND THENE ECOND RE POR THEREST
OTHER -- SCE WE
CASAID, DEMANEHIGHER, BUTLS HIGF
CA VACCINCH
FRANKLY SURPRISED HOWT
VISITING PLA TO SEE
HOW MUCH ,
PRODUCE.EAC AR THE ELTI
>>YES.E S EXACTLY
THIS TIME.WE IT WE
LE IT.ULTIPLTIS,ELECTI IIAL.
I  PREDICTING THIS WOULD
ENHE
OCTO E WEEK LATER, BSE T
WHEN SCIENCEIT>>> AND SANJAY JS
NOW. SEEMS
THISDO YOU AGREE TT TH
A GAME C THEPAEMHI THEOL ANDF AE
THE THA VACCINEALABTTRAJEC O W.T
WITHIM THEAS
OPTHE REAL QUESTION  THI HELPPR
O ANDUERITYF DIS SAVE LIVES?
WEAVATAT.
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE SAFETYDAT,
THIS WOULD BE ANT
AY LATER THIS  BUT W THISINRM SU
ABOUT THLA A
OFPOSITIVE,
HOUSING SECRE BEN CARSON.NOTA B
FIGURES.HEN  OWS, OF COURSE, HA.
I'VEIM FORYWE A AT TH SEAD OF B.
I WAS SURPRISED FORHAT RE
AS PN,TAND THIS VIRUS BETTER,HE
THE BEFITS OF WEANG
IT JUSTOAT MESIT WHIUSE.
I GUAEE YOU, B CARSOKNOWS TIT'S.
HE JT IS NOT DOI
HE KNOWSE AMESSAGE BY NOT DOING
HE IS REGDERES,OUT.
S ONEY,ED BY IT, V IS POWERFUHIG
IGHT THING WITH